the Joe Rogan experience what was the
last second ellic trip you had any I did
mushrooms couple months ago yeah how is
that it's [ __ ] awesome where'd you do
him
um did him with re on the show we did
did him during a podcast really yeah and
do you guys start tripping during the
podcast yeah yeah we're having fun what
is what does it sound like it was great
podcast was great
we didn't take too much yeah we took
enough and what like you know no one can
tell when you're on them like you can
still function normally yeah I mean it
depends on how far you go please you
guys are so funny yeah you can go down
the rabbit hole
okay I'm you can go down the rabbit hole
and be incoherent mm-hmm
mushrooms it's dose-dependent I mean
what you're doing is like you're getting
you know you take a little bit you're
like shaking hands with the Angels but
you're not going to heaven
you're not going to visit them you're
like hi how are you oh my god you're so
wonderful
but you're not like riding on their
wings going going to the other dimension
but if you take enough that's where you
go if you take enough you're not talking
to anybody and have you done Alice T yes
and good yes great experience yeah oh
you had a bad experience on that no no I
took it I took it later in life I don't
think it's I think most of these
psychedelics where you have bad
experiences what you're having is your
own psychological dilemma and then your
battle with whatever the the drug or the
psychedelic is trying to do to you
versus what your ego is trying to
control and keep it from happening I
mean I've seen a lot of people have bad
trips on some of the worst trips I've
ever seen people have was from edible
pot edible pot is one of the strongest
things that people don't recognize
mm-hmm it's it's a very different drug
than smoking it and when you know you
when you think of things that can take
you down the rabbit hole
you don't think of edible pot people
think of pot is just like oh you're
gonna get a high maybe you can get too
high but you're just getting high but
boom when you eat it it's a completely
different animal yeah literally like
physiologically it's a different really
yeah it's create something called 11
hydroxy metabolite that's five times
more psychoactive than THC and what it's
like not even psychoactive in smoking it
it's a different drug that's a little
different totally different drug that
makes complete sense yeah it's a
different drug it's processed by your
liver well there's something called the
one pass that passes through your liver
and the THC gets processed into eleven
hydroxy metabolites Google it's trippy
[ __ ]
I've way stronger registered on some
Micro dos versions of mushrooms that I
have to add two of them and they were it
was great it just made things a little
bit brighter
have you ever microdose yes you know
does that all-time hey white oh really
Ron white so micro dosing [ __ ]
yeah cuz I'm on this new drug it's
called mushrooms and I just take a
little bit every day woah yeah I know a
lot of people to do that yeah a lot like
dozens dozens of people who microdose
including fighters I know a lot of
fighters from microdose yeah I forgot
today was even on any I was like I was
just like oh this room looks like cooler
yeah I just feel so oh yeah I ate that
little piece yeah you just feel a little
better and you're like what is all I
took mushrooms yeah I forgot
[Applause]